[موسيقى]
تم تصميمها لتحل محل القذفه المقاتله اف
84 اف كما انها دخلت الى الخدمه في سلاح
الجو الامريكي في العام
1959 لتكون طائره الهجوم والسيطره الجويه
الاساسيه في حرب فيتنام تم تزويد مقاتله
الاف مئه وخمسه بمدفع رشاش من طراز فولكن
متعدد الفوهات من عيار 20 مليمتر هذا
بالاضافه الى صواريخ المضاده للطائرات
[موسيقى]
قتله كانت لديها قدره على حمل ما يقرب من
سته اطنان من القنابل والصواريخ بالاضافه
الى قدرتها على حمل قنبله نوويه
[موسيقى]
خضعت هذه الطائره لعدد من التعديلات من
بينها مثلا توسيع قمره القياده لتتسع
لتيارين وكذلك تحويلها الى طائره متخصصه
في استهداف صواريخ السام اثنين كما تم
تسليحها بصواريخ من طراز الشرايط الذي
يتتبع موجات الراديو ويدمر منصات الرادار
التي توجه صواريخ
[موسيقى]
تم انتاج
833 طائره من هذه المقاتله الا اسقاط عدد
كبير منها وكذلك كثره المشكلات الفنيه
التي واجهتها مثلا ارتفاع درجه حراره
المحرك وكذلك تسريبات الوقود كل هذه
الامور دفعت القوات الجويه الامريكيه
لسحبها ولكن بشكل تدريجي حتى خرجت تماما
من الخدمه في عام 1980 هذا بحسب موقع
المتحف الوطني للقوات الجويه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]